[Musique]
vous attend dans votre bureau
allez une Ruby Carlos ne vous a pas fait
entrer ah oui lui aussi mise à jour
c'est ma fille elle a disparu et sa
camarade de chambre aussi
sa chambre et au campus Alan Turing
qu'est-ce qu'elle pouvait avoir en
commun le proviseur il va vous montrer
l'enregistrement
j'ai essayé
une
on a localisé l'Android
vous voyez ça il sait pas laisser faire
le gars et venez voir par ici
[Musique]
tu comprends pas pourquoi construire un
vaisseau spatial
quel choix à faire ce robot
sa fille soupçonnée
regarde ce que je vois en thermique vous
avez des prostituées humaines il y a que
du synthétique mais nous nous
considérons comme 100% humain pas vrai
monsieur
un logiciel pour prendre le contrôle
total d'un robots
[Musique]